C’est quoi ça ?
Attend, mais c’est une météorite.
Tu fais quoi avec un œuf de Yoni toi ?
Un quoi ?
On vend la météorite, mais on dit que c’est une pierre magique.
Et ça, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça, ça veut dire qu’il l’a déjà vendu.
Nan mais arrête, t’es glauque là.
Non mais le mec a avalé un caillou,
c’est fou quand même.
Nan mais attend, il y a quand même plus intéressant qu’un mec qui avale un caillou parce qu’il fait un bad trip.
Ah ouais tu trouves ? moi je trouve ça marrant.
Le mec a pas avalé un caillou, mais un œuf de Yoni.
Une météorite, il a avalé une météorite, alors c’est encore plus marrant.
Je suis vraiment désolé pour ce mec-là,
mais il y a quand même des choses plus intéressantes qui se passent dans le monde,
en Afrique, en Asie…
documentez-vous.
Mais c’est le mec du bon coin,
c’est notre caillou qu’il a avalé.
QUOI ?
Tu vois que c’est pas si inintéressant les faits divers.
Je ne vais pas vous jeter la pierre, moi aussi j’ai une fascination pour les faits divers un peu glauques.
Mon historique peut en témoigner,
j’ai énormément lu sur les tueurs en série, les faits divers un peu médiatisés…
bref si la police a accès à mon historique Wikipédia, je pense qu’il ne faut pas que je tarde à planifier ma fuite vers l’étranger.
La question qu’il faut se poser, plutôt que de se culpabiliser, c’est pourquoi ?
Pourquoi aime-t-on autant les faits divers ?
Pourquoi aime-t-on autant lire des articles qui nous donnent des détails dont on se passerait bien,
puisque ce n’est clairement pas de l’information
dont on peut faire quelque chose ?
Il n’y a qu’à voir le succès des “Faites entrer l’accusé”, “Affaires criminelles”
ou les documentaires sur l’affaire Grégory, Luka Magnotta et j’en passe.
Ça soulève beaucoup de questions !
Mais qu’est-ce-qui relève du fait divers et qu’est-ce-qui n’en relève pas ?
Un fait divers, c’est un événement plus ou moins important
qui ne relève ni de l'actualité mondiale, ni de la politique, ni de l'économie.
On peut regrouper dedans les accidents, les catastrophes naturelles,
les enlèvements, les meurtres etc.
Pour info, en argot journalistique, on appelle ça “chien écrasé”.
Le fait divers, c’est un peu ce papier que l’on trouve dans les journaux ou sur Internet,
sur lequel on a pas forcément beaucoup de détails et qui n’est pas toujours repris par la suite.
Et puis des fois, certains faits divers font l’objet d’une couverture médiatique plus importante.
Parfois, pour des questions de timing,
Par exemple, le plus grave accident de TGV en France a été passé quasi sous silence,
puisqu’il s’est produit en même temps que les attentats du Bataclan.
Là, c’est assez compréhensible,
mais parfois, les raisons d’une médiatisation importante sont un petit peu plus mystérieuses.
Par exemple, si je vous dis “mère infanticide”,
vous allez probablement penser en premier à Véronique Courjault,
condamnée pour 3 infanticides.
Mais vous ne penserez peut-être pas à Dominique Cottrez,
qui a été médiatisée aussi mais qui est moins restée dans l’imaginaire collectif,
alors qu’elle a été condamné pour 8 infanticides.
Du coup, à partir de quand un fait divers est-il présenté comme un fait de société ?
Ce serait les médias
qui en fonction de leur traitement et de l’importance dans la presse
feraient basculer le fait divers au fait tout court ?
Alors je vais pas vous apprendre combien on a une fascination pour le hors norme puisque mon coloc vous l’a déjà expliqué.
Ah oui d’ailleurs, c’est moi qui avait raison.
Pas du tout, pas du tout, tu dis toujours que c’est des monstres.
MAIS C’EST DES MONSTRES.
Pas du tout. Mais n’importe quoi.
Mais si c’est des monstres ! C’est ça qu’est cool, c’est des monstres.
Oui, on a tendance à être fasciné par globalement tout ce qui sort de la norme.
Les criminels nous semblent très éloignés de nous,
on se dit qu’on ne commettrait jamais de telles  atrocités.
On cherche à comprendre leur état d’esprit, ce qui les pousse à passer à l’acte.
Ces personnes mettent à mal notre idée de cohésion de la société, d’ordre public
et ça c’est une notion très juridique, d’où notre fascination à leur égard.
Et notre fascination provoque parfois des réactions assez fortes,
comme lorsqu’on qualifie les criminels de “monstre” par exemple.
Marquer une telle opposition, ça permet de créer un sentiment de supériorité,
ça donne de la force à des discours qui vont considérer que la violence ou la torture à l’égard des bourreaux
est légitime, voire souhaitable.
Et ça, ben en tant que juriste, vous comprendrez bien que ça me chiffonne un petit peu !
Le souci c’est qu’employer le terme de monstre est une façon de les déshumaniser.
Ça les éloigne de notre condition d’être humain,
ça entretient l’idée qu’on naît criminel alors que, globalement, on a plutôt tendance à le devenir.
Du coup, ce n’est pas quelque chose qui va vraiment nous aider à comprendre ce qu’il se passe dans la tête d’un criminel,
alors que c’est le résultat d’une multiplicité de facteurs, dont des facteurs socio-culturels.
Et ça ben dans la presse, on n’en parle pas suffisamment.
Déjà parce-que ça devient un peu technique et puis ça fait moins réagir.
Et le problème c’est que cette fascination pour le glauque et le morbide,
donc pour certains faits divers,
a des effets secondaires assez importants sur notre société.
Les faits divers occupent une grande place dans l’actualité,
parce-qu’ils font vendre, qu’ils génèrent du clic et de l’engagement.
Il y a tout un processus narratif autour des faits,
puisqu’on y retrouve des éléments comme une situation initiale,
un élément perturbateur,
différents protagonistes.
On ne sait pas encore tout, des mystères restent encore à éclaircir.
Que s’est-il passé exactement ?
Qui est le coupable, et a-t-il agi seul ?
Pour quelles raisons ?
Certains documentaires ou reportages ne varient pas beaucoup de la fiction,
puisqu’on retrouve le même schéma de narration,
on joue sur notre corde sensible,
avec de la mise en scène, une musique dramatique, le blouson en cuir de Christophe Hondelatte,
et c’est peut-être cela qui nous rend si réceptifs.
On peut donc dire que les faits divers captent notre attention.
S’ils génèrent de l’argent, on va forcément les mettre en avant,
du coup on va plus avoir tendance à consommer cette information
et paf, c’est un peu un cercle vicieux.
Mais ça, vous le savez déjà.
Sauf que,
pour vendre de l’information exclusive et des détails croustillants,
la presse prend des fois des risques inconsidérés.
On se souvient bien sûr de l’affaire du petit Grégory
où Bernard Laroche avait été inculpé en quasi direct à la télé
et proclamé comme l’assassin de l’enfant,
sans trop respecter la présomption d’innocence.
Pour rappel, la présomption d’innocence,
c’est le fait de considérer qu’une personne est innocente
tant qu’elle n’a pas été condamnée par un tribunal pour ses actes.
D’où l’utilité d’utiliser “présumé” et de réviser son conditionnel !
De façon plus récente, on se souvient aussi de l’attentat de l’HyperCacher en janvier 2015
où BFMTV avait révélé que certains otages s’étaient réfugiés dans la chambre froide.
une information qui aurait pu mettre en péril leur sécurité si elle était parvenue au terroriste,
merci BFM !
Dans le même genre, et toujours chez BFM, décidément,
on a ce titre complètement délirant qui a dû tourner en boucle à l’époque,
“Attentats: ce que les terroristes ont dit à BFMTV”,
oui parce que, BFM a tenté de joindre des témoins
alors que les terroristes s’étaient retranchés dans l’imprimerie.
Sauf qu’il y avait un otage encore une fois,
et ça aurait pu terriblement mal tourner.
Les médias, notamment les chaines télé d’info en continu
filment parfois les assauts des forces de police pour mettre fin aux prises d’otage.
A-t-on vraiment besoin de cette information en direct ?
Qu’est-ce-que ça nous apporte à part du voyeurisme ?
Le direct n’est par définition pas prévisible,
il a des aléas,
et nous sommes comme spectateurs devant notre télé ou notre fil d’actualité d’un réseau social quelconque.
S’il est tentant d’être informé au plus vite, pour être au coeur de l’action et de l’actualité,
il ne faudrait pas consommer ce type d’informations de la même façon qu’un divertissement.
Bon, je ne vais pas tirer sur l’ambulance
car les médias se sont un peu faits tirer les oreilles par l’opinion public et les autorités après de tels couacs,
mais je pense qu’on sera tous relativement d’accords pour dire que ces comportements
ne doivent surtout pas être reproduits.
M’enfin quand même, on avait peut-être pas besoin d’expérimenter le truc pour se rendre compte que ça posait de sacrés problèmes, ché pa moi.
Ce qui me chagrine aussi très fort, c’est que les faits divers sont souvent traités rapidement,
avec des grosses, des énormes erreurs de droit.
Pourquoi ? Parce que les journalistes sont aussi tenus par des objectifs de rentabilité,
ils doivent publier vite, ils n’ont pas forcément le temps d’approfondir le sujet autant qu’ils le voudraient.
On ne peut pas totalement leur jeter la pierre,
puisqu’après tout, ils n’ont pas tous une formation de juriste !
Et autant vous dire que 5 ans sur les bancs de la fac ne suffisent pas pour faire de vous un bon juriste.
alors si en plus vous n’avez pas fait une formation spécialisée dans le droit,
forcément les papiers ne seront pas toujours rigoureux malheureusement.
Nan parce que des fois, votre manque de rigueur, c’est insupportable.
Oui bah, bon, on fait ce qu’on peut.
Est-ce qu’il n’y aurait pas un biais cognitif qui ferait qu’on
se souviendrait un peu plus des égarements journalistiques ?
Parce que, quand on regarde bien, il y a quand même une masse
de contenus qui sont produits chaque jour.
On n’est pas des grands méchants, nous, les journalopes,
on fait ce qu’on peut pour essayer de bien faire notre boulot. Parce qu’on a une éthique.
Après, il y a franchement une charte qui existe. C’est la charte de Munich,
c’est en gros la référence en déontologie journalistique à l’échelle européenne.
Et elle, elle nous dit que la mission d’information comporte nécessairement des limites
que les journalistes s’imposent eux-mêmes spontanément.
En gros, c’est vraiment laisser à l’appréciation de chacun. Y a un espèce de flou artistique.
Mais c’est sûr après qu’il y a tout un truc autour du scoop.
Quand tu t’engages en journalisme, en général, les gens qui
qui se sentent investi d’une mission, c’est un peu pour faire leur Elise Lucet, pour découvrir des choses,
pour faire changer le monde.
Et le scoop, ça s’inscrit complètement dans cette logique-là.
Moi-même, je l’ai expérimenté.
C’est un exemple un peu nul.
Mais j’ai passé une nuit blanche pour passer une info avant tout le monde.
Pour avoir mon scoop.
Et en fait, c’était juste pour dire qu’on avait retrouvé un squelette
d’un éléphant d’une espèce disparue en France.
J’étais trop fière de moi.
Mais je me dis : “est-ce que ça vaut le coup de passer une nuit blanche à travailler,
pour sortir cette info qui a été oublié dès le lendemain."
Mais de toutes façons, je ne sais pas si ça vaut vraiment le coup de taper sur les journalistes. C’est vraiment le dernier maillon de la chaîne.
En fait, c’est tout le système qui est pourri. Il y a vraiment une course à la rentabilité.
On doit produire toujours plus. On doit faire deux, trois, quatre, cinq, six articles par jour.
Forcément, tu n’as pas le temps de bien creuser pour chercher les informations et tout
Après, heureusement, ce n’est pas pareil partout dans tous les médias.
J’ai eu beaucoup de chance de ce côté-là.
À mon avis, le problème, c’est de trouver un modèle économique
viable pour la presse.
Parce qu’à l’heure actuelle, la plupart des titres de presse sont complètement à perte.
Ah mais en fait, le problème, c’est la capitalisme.
Le lexique, je vais y revenir, mais ce dont je pourrais parler, j’en ai déjà parlé dans l’épisode d’Un Créatif sur la pub mensongère,
c’est que tu peux utiliser du conditionnel, des adverbes comme probablement,
peut-être, ce genre de trucs, ce genre de construction
pour rajouter des hypothèses, des théories qui ne sont pas du tout étayées,
mais qui permettent un peu de rendre le truc un peu plus glauque,
un peu plus voyeur.
Ca mange pas de pain et c’est quelque chose d’assez régulier.
Les gens retiennent souvent de genre de choses.
Et en terme de lexique, il y a des trucs. Il y a des trucs, tu sais que si c’est là, y a eu un délire.
Genre “garçonnet” quoi.
Si t’as le mot garçonnet dans un article, tu sais que le gamin il a mal fini.
Il a peut-être fini dans la Vologne ou il a fini
il a fini tué ou à la benne, tu sais pas,
Mais jamais tu vas dire : “Je suis allé chercher le pain avec mon garçonnet.”.
Jamais tu ne parles comme ça de tes enfants, par exemple.
Pareil, tu ne vas jamais chez Casto ou je sais pas quoi pour acheter de la cordelette.
Le mec qui vient acheter de la cordelette, faut appeler le 17.
Pour moi, la cordelette, ça sert à attacher un cadavre,
attacher un garçonnet éventuellement.
Pareil, une fillette.
La fillette, pour moi, c’est la petite fille qu’a vécu un petit coup dur.
On dit jamais : “Je suis avec ma petite fillette là”. Non jamais.
Jamais.
Du coup, si tu as un gars qu’a un van, qui va acheter de la cordelette, et qui a un garçonnet et une fillette à l’arrière.
tu sais déjà de base,
que c’est un fait divers ou une affaire judicière. En tout cas un truc pas terrible.
Du coup, ces faits divers entretiennent notre méconnaissance du droit,
car on n’a pas vraiment le temps de faire de la vulgarisation en même temps.
On ne peut pas expliquer la procédure, parce que c’est une discipline complexe et exigeante.
On ne peut pas prendre le temps d’expliquer la différence entre un assassinat et un homicide volontaire,
alors que c’est pourtant une distinction ultra importante.
Ah parce que c’est pas la même chose ?
Bah non, un assassinat, c’est forcément prémédité,
et un homicide volontaire, c’est pas toujours prémédité.
Et ces informations parcellaires,
rapides entraînent aussi l’idée d’une justice laxiste,
qui laisserait les criminels dans la nature
et ne condamnerait qu’à des peines symboliques.
On ne prend pas le temps d’expliquer pourquoi on décide par exemple de recourir à un bracelet électronique,
pourquoi on fait une remise de peine
ou pourquoi après un appel, on relâche le présumé alors qu’il avait été condamné quelques années plus tôt.
Toutes ces informations vont créer une confusion
dans la tête des gens, qui vont souvent avoir tendance à être énervé
face aux décisions de justice dont ils ont vent
car ils ne les comprennent pas.
t loin de moi l’idée de les culpabiliser car c’est normal.
Une décision de justice quand on n’est pas juriste,
c’est tout simplement impossible à comprendre
et les médias ne peuvent pas retranscrire dans son intégralité
la complexité du dossier.
Il faut juste garder en tête que s’il y a eu plusieurs années d’enquête,
plusieurs jours de procès et des questions d’interprétation de la règle de droit,
aucun article de presse non-spécialisée ne peut retranscrire toute la complexité de ce dossier.
Et on ne peut pas se faire un avis sans avoir assisté au procès et avoir tenu le dossier entre les mains.
Enfin, on peut avoir son avis mais il faut rester prudent sur cette question
et ne pas considérer que les juges ont mal fait leur travail,
car c’est un peu insultant pour eux vu le temps qu’ils y passent
et vu l’étendue des informations dont ils disposent.
Du coup cette idée préconçue d’une justice laxiste entretient la crise de confiance
qu’ont les Français dans l’institution judiciaire.
C’est quand même ballot et c’est même très inquiétant,
puisque ce sont peut-être des personnes qui vont se détourner de notre justice institutionnelle,
soit en ne faisant rien alors qu’ils pourraient peut-être obtenir gain de cause,
soit en se faisant justice elles-mêmes.
La multiplication des faits divers, et particulièrement s’ils sont violents,
vont aussi amener les individus à réclamer une justice plus répressive.
Bref, aucune de ces solutions n’est réellement satisfaisante.
L’autre versant de cette image d’une justice laxiste,
c’est qu’on a tendance à totalement sur-évaluer la criminalité,
ce qui rejoint le biais de négativité,
c'est à dire qu’on accorde plus d’attention aux informations négatives,
on les retient mieux que le positif,
et ça, vous et moi, on aura du mal à avoir un contrôle dessus.
Sauf que statistiquement, les faits divers et autres crimes abominables
ne sont qu’une toute petite partie des infractions globales.
Et quand on regarde la presse, c’est pas du tout l’impression qu’on a,
on a même le sentiment que c’est plutôt l’inverse !
En 2013, l’INA a même estimé que le nombre de faits divers dans les JT
a augmenté de 73% en 10 ans !
Et pourtant, notre taux de criminalité n’a pas du tout suivi la même courbe, je vous rassure !
Au contraire même, puisqu’on voit une sacrée chute des statistiques,
pour 1 000 habitants, on passe d’un taux de 68,9 en 2002 à 54,6 en 2012.
D’ailleurs, le Ministère de la Justice publie chaque année les statistiques concernant le nombre d’infractions pénales
et je vous conseille au passage d’y faire un tour parce-que c’est une mine d’or d’informations, vous retrouvez ces sources dans la description !
On y apprend que pour l’année 2018 par exemple,
on recense un peu moins de 2300 crimes pour...
545.000 délits.
Bon, alors c’est pas si étonnant puisque la catégorie des délits,
elle regroupe beaucoup plus d’infractions pénales différentes que les crimes.
Mais quand même, ça fait un facteur multiplicateur de 237,
c’est pas rien !
Petit récap’ rapidos du juriste en herbe.
En France, on regroupe toutes nos infractions pénales en 3 catégories par ordre de gravité :
les contraventions, qui vont du tapage nocturne à l’injure non publique en passant par le fait de pas avoir de ticket de métro ;
les délits qui regroupent des infractions plus graves que les contraventions et il y en a énormément :
diffamation en public, violences volontaires, agressions sexuelles, abus de biens sociaux…
Et sachez au passage que l’homicide involontaire est un délit et non pas un crime.
Parce qu’il faut qu’il y ait intention de tuer pour que ce soit considéré un crime ;
et donc la catégorie la plus grave, les crimes.
Forcément, si c’est la catégorie la plus grave,
on doit la réserver à quelques infractions seulement,
sinon la hiérarchie aurait moins de sens.
Dans les crimes, on retrouve le vol à main armée, le viol, la réduction en esclavage, le meurtre, le génocide,
bref toutes les infractions les plus violentes et les plus attentatoires à notre intégrité physique ou à notre dignité.
Bref, plein de joyeusetés diverses et variées.
Donc, comme je vous disais, pour l’année 2018, 2300 crimes pour 545 000 délits.
Bon c’est beaucoup en soi, je dis pas le contraire,
et puis on compte pas tous ceux qui passés sous silence.
Mais quand même, notre taux de délinquance et de criminalité n’est pas en pleine explosion,
et malheureusement les médias ont plutôt tendance à laisser penser le contraire.
Et en surévaluant le nombre de faits divers, surtout les plus sanguinaires et terribles,
cela entretient un sentiment d’insécurité
qui est bien au-dessus des réalités statistiques.
On ne peut pas nier qu’effectivement, dans certaines villes, il y a plus de délits et de crimes qu’ailleurs, c’est vrai.
Mais c’est dû à d’autres critères, comme la pauvreté, l’exclusion, le chômage, etc.
ce qui rarement pris en compte comme il se doit par les médias parce-qu’on va pas en plus s’emmerder avec la sociologie.
Plus sérieusement, il est complexe d’expliquer ces grandes problématiques sociales,
elles mobilisent beaucoup de connaissances différentes, elles demandent de croiser plein de sources,
d’expliquer différents points de vue qui parfois se contredisent parce-que dans les sciences sociales, on est pas toujours d’accord.
Le journal télévisé ou les petites brèves de presse ne peuvent pas faire le travail d’un documentaire long et complexe,
accessible à tous.
Et ce n’est pas ce qu’on leur demande, mais on pourrait éventuellement repenser la place qu’on offre à ces documents de fond aux heures de grandes écoutes.
Bon alors on a parlé de la responsabilité de la presse,
de la surévaluation de la criminalité
et de la crise de confiance que pouvaient avoir les gens dans l’institution,
mais concrètement, chez les juristes, ça se passe comment les faits divers ?
Et ben c’est très embêtant, on va pas se mentir. Surtout quand il y a un emballement médiatique.
Bon déjà, le fait que les gens doutent de l’institution,
c’est dur pour ceux qui travaillent sans cesse pour l’améliorer.
Travailler des années sur un dossier pour qu’on fasse un tweet méprisant sur le fait qu’on ne sait pas faire son boulot,
c’est un peu rude,
mais c’est peut-être que ça fait partie du job finalement.
Sauf que des fois ça a des conséquences directes sur l’enquête.
Je vous ai parlé de l’affaire Grégory un peu plus tôt,
c’est effectivement l’un des premiers exemples qui nous viennent en tête,
mais il y en a plein d’autres.
Et l’affaire dont je voudrais principalement parler ici, c’est l’affaire d’Outreau.
Houla !
L’affaire d’Outreau est une affaire très très très complexe,
et je n’aurais pas le temps de vous expliquer toutes les étapes et toutes les nuances.
Mais pour résumer grossièrement, souvenez vous que c’est une affaire de pédocriminalité
dans le début des années 2000
où pas moins de 17 personnes sont accusées d’abus sexuels sur mineurs.
Évidemment, cette affaire a fait la une des journaux,
ce qui est bien normal vu la gravité des faits
et surtout, le nombre de personnes concernées.
Et on voit même encore des titres à ce sujet car les rebondissements liés à cette affaire ne sont pas terminés.
Dans l’affaire d’Outreau, on a reconnu que de nombreux mineurs ont été effectivement victimes de viols, d’agressions sexuelles et de proxénétisme.
Concernant les accusés, certains ont été condamnés, d’autres, et c’est la majorité d’entre eux, sont acquittés.
Globalement, s’il y a bien une chose sur laquelle on s’accorde, c’est le chaos juridique que  représente cette affaire judiciaire,
qui a mis en lumière beaucoup de dysfonctionnements.
Beaucoup iront même jusqu’à parler de “fiasco” ou de “naufrage judiciaire”.
AMBIAAANCE.
Pour éviter de reproduire les erreurs commises,
une commission d’enquête parlementaire s’est penchée sur le sujet
et pour vous résumer en gros, y'a pas un échelon qui a pas cafouillé dans cette histoire.
On n’a pas respecté la présomption d’innocence,
on n’a pas été suffisamment rigoureux dans l’analyse des témoignages,
le juge d’instruction travaillait seul en ayant trop de pouvoirs,
le manque de budget alloué à la Justice s’est fait ressentir,
et la liste des couacs est encore longue !
Ce sur quoi on va se pencher spécifiquement, c’est le rôle des médias et du coup, de la pression qu’elle engendre.
Je tiens vraiment à insister sur le fait que ce ne sont pas les seuls responsables
et qu’il y a eu plein de raisons pour laquelle l’affaire d’Outreau a été un naufrage,
il s’agit d’une responsabilité multiple dont il est difficile de déterminer exactement la part de chacun.
Quoiqu’il en soit, les médias ont énormément manqué de prudence sur le sujet,
en ne respectant pas la présomption par exemple.
Vous remarquerez d’ailleurs que dans de nombreuses erreurs judiciaires, comme l’affaire de Patrick Dils par exemple,
il est pointé du doigt a posteriori que les médias n’avaient effectivement pas respecté cette présomption d’innocence
et cela pose un vrai problème.
Spécifiquement sur l’affaire d’Outreau, on s’est précipité,
on n’a pas suffisamment vérifié les informations
et plusieurs journalistes estiment que certains principes journalistiques et déontologiques ont été bafoués.
Dans son livre “La Méprise” édité par Seuil et sorti en octobre 2015,
la journaliste Florence Aubenas va rapporter qu’elle a vu vent
que le juge d’instruction Florent Burgaud commettait certains excès,
sauf que le juge Michel Gasteau va ensuite pointer le manque de rigueur de son ouvrage,
voire sa malhonnêteté intellectuelle.
Effectivement, Florence Aubenas a rapporté des éléments faux.
Elle a apparemment rajouté des commentaires qu’aurait fait le juge mais qui n’ont jamais existé.
Elle a inversé la place dans la salle d’audience des accusés et des victimes également.
Elle a également avancé qu’elle avait eu accès à l’intégrité du dossier,
ce qui n’est pas possible puisque l’affaire était encore soumise au secret de l’enquête.
Et ben, bon courage pour démêler le vrai du faux dans tout ça.
Globalement, je crois que ça rend bien compte d’une certaine confusion dans l’esprit de chacun,
ce qui ne sert ni la Justice, ni les accusés ou les victimes,
et aggrave la crise de confiance à l’égard des journalistes.
Ce qui est encore plus enquiquinant, c’est que le livre de Florence Aubenas,
alors journaliste à Libération,
est sorti avant que se tienne le procès en appel.
Il énonce des éléments du dossier, qui donc, pour certains, sont considérés donc comme faux.
Et vous n’êtes pas sans savoir que lorsqu’un procès se tient devant une cour d’assises,
il y a des jurés, tirés au sort, sans formation de juriste.
Ils n’ont pas le même rôle ni le même poids qu’aux Etats-Unis, puisqu’ils sont encadrés par un magistrat professionnel.
Mais dans ces jurés, peut-être que certains ont lu le livre de Florence Aubenas.
Peut-être que cela a pu influencer leur décision, dans un sens comme dans un autre.
Et si les éléments avancés sont faux,
on biaise totalement leur vision
et la potentielle décision à venir.
On n’a aucune certitude que c’est effectivement le cas.
Mais rien que la possibilité puisse exister, c’est déjà trop.
Que ce genre d’analyses après le procès existe ne pose pas vraiment de problème.
L’affaire est close, il n’y a pas d’influence sur la décision de justice.
Le but n’est pas de fermer le débat et de le restreindre aux seuls acteurs judiciaires,
ça ne serait pas très démocratique.
Mais que ce livre ait pu être publié à quelques semaines seulement du procès d’appel en énonçant des choses fausses,
là ça pose un très sérieux problème de déontologie.
Pourtant, dans le Code pénal, il existe un article,
le 434-16,
qui punit « la publication, avant l’intervention de la décision juridictionnelle définitive,
de commentaires tendant à exercer des pressions en vue d’influencer les déclarations des témoins
ou la décision des juridictions d’instruction ou de jugement ».
Un autre article, le 434-25, incrimine « la volonté de jeter
le discrédit sur un acte ou une décision juridictionnelle
lequel serait de nature à porter atteinte à l’autorité de la Justice ou à son indépendance ».
Alors ne me demandez pas pourquoi Florence Aubenas n’a pas été poursuivie sur les fondements de ces articles,
c’est un mystère à mes yeux, alors que pourtant, on est en plein dedans là.
A défaut de sanctions envers ce type d’agissements,
qui n’est pas le seul fait de Florence Aubenas,
il serait préférable que certains journalistes tirent eux-mêmes des conclusions sur l’influence qu’ils peuvent avoir
sur certaines issues d’affaires médiatisées.
Et comme disait le sociologue Pierre Bourdieu, « Le fait-divers fait diversion ».
Bref, l’idée n’est pas de dépeindre le grand méchant média rempli de “journalopes”,
parce que vous savez, j’ai longtemps voulu être journaliste, alors ce serait très malvenu de ma part.
Je suis intimement persuadée que les journalistes ne cherchent pas sciemment à manipuler l’opinion par tous les moyens
mais il faut être très très prudent, j’insiste,
dès qu’on touche aux affaires juridiques.
Parce que clairement, des non-spécialistes accaparent souvent la parole au détriment de professionnels plus rigoureux.
On est touché par ces affaires terribles et on a envie que notre opinion compte
en espérant pouvoir faire évoluer la société dans un sens plus favorable.
Mais il faut être conscient des limites dans son expertise
et dans nos connaissances du dossier pour ne pas sombrer dans une justice populaire
et de ne pas rejeter l’institution judiciaire quand on ne sait pas exactement comment elle fonctionne.
Et puis, sous le régime soviétique, les journaux n’avaient pas le droit de relayer les faits divers,
parce que ça aurait pu sous-entendre qu’il y avait des failles dans le système.
Donc je préfère peut-être qu’on les relaie plutôt que de trop brider la liberté de la presse,
mais je pense qu’on peut tout de même arriver à un juste équilibre.
Bref, ne vous culpabilisez pas TROP si vous aimez les faits divers.
Après tout, je dois bien vous avouer que c’est peut être ces articles qui m’ont poussé à faire des études de droit
parce que je voulais comprendre plus en détails,
et sans ça, ben je serai pas en train de vous parler de tout ça à l’heure actuelle.
Faites juste très attention à vos sources,
sachez DOMPTER votre attention
et ne vous couchez pas trop tard parce-que vous êtes en train de lire
tous les articles wikipédia des tueurs en série de l’Ohio.
Je l’ai déjà fait, j’étais très très fatiguée le lendemain.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo, n’hésitez pas à la liker, à la partager sur vos réseaux sociaux,
à s’abonner à la chaîne et à activer la cloche,
et puis on se retrouvera sur Discord pour pouvoir en discuter tous ensemble.
Sur ce, je vous dis, à bientôt.
Elle était vraiment énervée Florence ?
Bah à ton avis, elle est partie.
En plus, elle s’est pris la tête avec Monté en passant.
Il fallait bien réparer la fenêtre. En plus, c’est elle qui a demandé.
Elle ne voulait pas qu’on arnaque un pauvre mec qu’a fini à l’hôpital parce qu’il pensait soigner ses brûlures d’estomac en avalant une roche.
Tu me comprends toi ?
T’as pas l’air énervée en tout cas.
Nan, j’suis pas énervée.
J’suis consternée.
Franchement, je ne sais pas si je vais tenir une semaine de plus avec vous tous ici,
ça commence à faire beaucoup.
Ah nan mais ce n'est pas du tout ce que vous croyez.
C'était pour un ami, il m'a posé des questions.
Et je voulais lui répondre.
On se retrouve sur Twitch ?
Tout de suite là maintenant en live, pour discuter de l'épisode, aller c'est parti !